hello and welcome to this video playing
a comma in the house yeah you see my
rating has suffered really I played a
couple of games between sessions to warm
up and it was terrible oh it's losing on
time from good positions you know the
deal and I'm already sick of that I just
have to say it like that I'm sick of
that so I'm just going to be I'm just
playing quicker now I did kind of it's
useless it's too frustrating losing all
those games on time so I'm just going to
play a lot quicker now and if it's yeah
I just I just want to try what happens
if i increase the speed so we have a
queen's gambit here some Queens gambit
exchange type of position Bishop g3 it's
kind of normal i think you trading off
the dark squared bishop okay that a
formal was pretty debatable he got a
five but as the thing this position
should be about equal what is an idea
here for me it's not difficult it's led
some probably for him there was a weird
way to start the sentence probably for
as an idea if he goes c5 he has to worry
about the week be five square i'm going
to try to go e form again c5 is
something that he has to be yeah he
needs to prepare properly so if is the
idea now okay this is something that was
certainly possible so I'm taking 92 and
now how is he covering this ya know b6
is dropping right do I go nite c4 or
queen Queen checks I think just clean
cakes sorry voice is a little bit a
little bit of
root can be eight maybe so many for is
still hanging kind of I mean or under
pressure let's say Quincy five is that a
move there i think i can do that takes
takes bishop 86 route 82 it's still I
can take your form and give them be too
hmm not quite sure look H we can go
route before ok so i think i'm going to
take this pawn and loop you one you can
takes Bishop d3 that's no good the night
should go to d4 somehow let's drive i
can go for that attack the c6 pawn so
I'm doing this regrouping if I'm
attacking the c6 porn will be difficult
i'm
hmm it's not easy to cover this pawn not
sure what king of a drilling this should
be seven is basically losing due to root
be one so I'm not quite sure what he's
doing now oopsie a drug be one also
looks bad brilliant I mean if c 6 45
faults that really looks lost why am I
missing some defense here I really don't
see anything for black
no see no defense whatsoever
again Bishop e7 rupee one listened in
some real awkward pins maybe Bishop e7
rook be one Bishop a8 as weird as it
looks okay it's doing this check through
p6 is coming ok getting a five ok let's
think for one moment i'm taking this
anyway where is it good i think this is
ups this is good getting the King to g3
so Chad it's a good spot for the king
it's covered ok first here night f5 is a
very good next move check here why can
go f3 maybe a f3 from f3 and f4 is
pretty good yeah trying to get the
bishop away from d5
yeah I think I know if for King e5 I can
take the bishop Kingda for tix on c6 and
I'm about two million pawns up in the
rook endgame black result the other
house working nicely the play quick idea
but anyway so let's let's have a look at
this game maybe he remembers that I'm
usually so sluggish and was kind of
irritated by that okay that that was all
pretty normal and now I went very
quickly like teak sticks and a for
taking I think it's okay if I'm not sure
about it it was a kind of a bullet mode
move well it gives me a weakness young
before but also makes a little bit
difficult for him to play c5 be sick is
also somewhat weak so maybe not the
greatest movie ever a four but I don't
think it's terrible ticks ticks this
engine wants to go Bishop a six not a
bad idea okay i'm preparing for a form
and now he got he got irritated and went
here and i think now that looks kind of
okay right before I some on the tech and
b6 so hmm f5 is not possible due to
chess rules and c5 d5 hmm it's
interesting i'm sitting on this this is
what the engine is giving with equal
play yeah very possible that those
weaknesses are kind of cancelling each
other out and he just blundered that
porn ready okay the computer doesn't
even want to move the Queen rook see one
yeah but I didn't feel like
experimenting there and went back you
should be same stakes let's I think I'm
probably better here but not not by much
because black is active but what oops
this here night f5 I'm not really sure
King King evaders probably not doing him
any good the engine is giving rook c2
which I don't quite understand can I
mean like this hmm this is what the
computer is giving I ok ok he gets to 2
/ 2 looks there hmmm cat this is the the
comm line with 0.3 now probably this
this is going to be traded and then I've
got four against three with this double
pong there there are the slide winning
chances everything is on one side of the
board the night is pretty good but it's
definitely better than this no black as
I think almost lost yeah this is
actually my line the line that I'd
suggest it's actually given by the
engine that looks really sick there with
the bishop but ideas to get it back but
probably doesn't help it just ma'am or
1.8 by the comm check chan yeah that's
just winning yeah that was a good good
kickoff for the play quickly approach
let's see what happens in the next games
thanks for watching